new motivation to subscibe hey it's Evan
Carmichael and this channel was created
to help you overcome the number one
challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something greater inside you as well
you've got Michael Jordan level talent
at something so get ready to follow your
dreams change your thinking and don't
wait for luck with Jack Ma and my take
on his top ten rules a success to give
you the confidence motivation and belief
that you need enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one follow your dreams in my apartment
where we started eighteen founders and
we aim high we have a dream we say we
want to make become the top 10 internet
companies or websites in the world guys
at that time we are ranking several
meaning name who is it won't be number
10 or the top 10 of the world we want to
make this company last 102 years and we
don't know where's our pay next mouth
well when you're poor if you have a
dreams you never feel poor you know what
we are doing so after we never say we
will be we will win next year or we win
tomorrow we say we will weigh in 10 20
years 19 years passed today we are the
top 10 websites coming to the
competition in the world remember to
change your thinking African desert ever
agree is that the eCos is not controlled
by lions and elephants the ecosystem is
controlled by the insects in the mud
last century the company the big the
better
so everybody want to be a big company
the powerful company this century from
now a good company is more important a
powerful company where you compete to is
become I think in past 20 years within
completing with any company lots of
companies in China
but I learned one thing no matter how
strong an elephant is if you're an INT
if you hide yourself well an elephant
cannot kill you you can kill the
elephant if you're in a better way
it's about your thinking rule number
three don't wait for luck
finchy faith heartily oh maybe it's over
that's a TA tanning system bladder so
what da Vinci Paulo so that's also pinch
itself whether it's an inch is higher is
inches of situations that were Mia rule
number four get used to being rejected
our first IP you years year 2007 when
Alibaba IPO in Hong Kong year 2007 we
had a lot of millionaires in the company
and I asked my friend my colleagues
alike we have like a 300 people become
millionaires
and I asked them eh now tell me you
become millionaires because you are
smarter than the others the people said
no no no no we even cut off by the jobs
because you are hardworking yes we were
happy we found more people hard-working
than us but they did not succeed one of
why they're not smart all the smart
people at that time they went to
Microsoft and IBM and headhunting
companies came to head and all the best
guy from us and we are the people nobody
cut the head
we have no place to go we believe in
ourself we believe our dream we work
together so I say we are the people
because nobody want us I am the person
over 30 companies don't want to make
right so we are the people get used to
be rejected where the people get used to
be say no from the other people why
people should help you people help you
that is unusual people do not help you
that is very common
you should work to end to be helped
also if you want to have more confidence
in self-love check out my 254 series
there free the link to join are in the
description below
it's so difficult to be a small business
in China it took me five months to bond
500 dollars
the people who do the bottom should
believe in the model and I believe what
I do remember five prove your worth KFC
has refused to hire you so with all
these know how at the end of the day
what has been the driver which has made
you who you are
yeah I wish people can say yes to me but
if they say yes I have no choice I
accept it and of course you're not happy
when people say no have a good sleep
wake up try it again it's always my
fault not the other people spot why you
can convince people if you cannot prove
it but the thing is that very important
there are two group of people you have
to convincing first group people your
team they believe in you they trust in
you and they believe the things we
agreed together and second is your
customers they really love your products
and investors it's okay rule number 6 be
resourceful for that she take a city
Chong yeah not at all
watch a mob become so a journalist I'm
watching you go your console this has
links to go
so he can show you this a 1 kg Omaha
really efficient to your Colonel what
this job what the chins in this or cook
up you watch are so you will Holloman by
the Tolly Haddad Toyota's they are
pussying emerge here RC with hydrogen
you initiate a you change it you have
until the soho taken either when he well
what are we can teach you the Veneto
possible chances achieve TV event it
occur to me are the sole primary so a
Honduran so voyage head or que canta
cigarette cheaper sister patum taking
has your sabbatical so it's a search
engine with Alibaba Kanazawa wire such
as Yahoo neurons on take a change in
subway Sam PGA Tour de Jacobson only
each of bouts and say and days of fungal
warmest even on a young and doctor so
the wage hand on your hand onii-chan
which are Coachella each are going to
the changes are you got what are the
Trinity Pacheco that's if they are don't
be she do you take a champion Roja yo-yo
chendo jet you with this country
war machine tourniquet rule number seven
never complained as entrepreneur
we never complain we make other people
complain we make our competitors
complain we never cry because if cry can
solve the problems because of no problem
we make competitors cry we make those
people who do not believe our dreams cry
remember eight embrace the change I
think people worry about jobs today we
think people worry about artificial
intelligence well don't worry too much
about that people are improving and
people working about a security eleva
but God in the past five years every day
we got a 300 million attacks per day but
we think the opportunity let's learn it
let's learn how to do it solve the
problems and then in the future where we
got experience share with the others
that's the whole thing so I want to get
encouraging everybody look at the future
we cannot avoid
we have to embrace it we have to live it
think about the future and there are a
lot of things my grandfather will never
be surprised we would be so surprised to
today human being have so many jobs can
be created
rule number nine act to the Duggar
chuluun iam Jovian was a while ago
decisions at you some better handle to a
verge a faithful who the courier in
turning the engine guy why a miserable
going about the missile if I end up good
cinema bar where you can't sometimes
your coochie Papa boring yeah well your
chill a bit such into thoughts which eat
sour and tangy your machines have a
girlfriend on your home meet other teams
had their war how soon you will not
release and on the heating guy change it
can you perhaps don't agree engine carry
ing me against God whether somebody has
to stop them so what your approach is
silica decision design has equality
jeans herself where an implicit equation
tau parameter in can over yet wait until
Hamlet uncle opposite way apart
[Music]
and I applaud Natalie your shoes and you
get a package so to learn illegal dance
when you saw so much oh yeah what hey
Pamela you're so hot for engine turns
engine to engine gas fish even a pudgy
Halliwell de Franchi Tom kalla pinay
yoga session gee you're not Hamid a guy
gets her soon hey Nate a man that you
saw was a hundred very political
Sicilian heart she learns or whichever
jingo wash I shall trigger has a mile
east of the city or the Sahara such as a
fashion PR Reuben he puts its head she
can charge of the shin don't take a pen
ha can you make when she ruined it enjoy
tension don't need Joe Cronin's is a got
three parts of the soul eater and rule
number ten the last one before a very
special bonus clip is fine your home
1999 we study the business and people
ask why not a Beijing Shanghai Guangzhou
I know Hangzhou is this hub of
entrepreneurs and startups and tech but
back then back then hands us know where
and and I think at that time Nokia was
so good at that time and I say guys
where's Nokia he's a thing that's some
small island headquarters there it's not
where you are I don't see it's where
your heart is where your vision is so we
said Beijing they love SOE stayed on the
business Shanghai tale of multinational
companies IBM Microsoft the embrace your
startup entrepreneur forget it right so
I said if in Beijing where nobody in
Shanghai where nobody if we go to back
to handle where the only child of the
local family
Oh stutters now I have a special bonus
clip from Jack on how to envision the
future that I think you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
three-point landing question let's go
from just watching the video to taking
some action here we go question number
one where do you need to stop
complaining number two where do you need
to better prove your worth and number
three where do you need to be more
resourceful and if you like this video
and will take action after watching it
give me a hashtag believe down the
comments as well if everybody agrees
then there is no opportunity when people
criticize you you have to think and I
spend most of my time thinking about the
future I spend most of time listen to
the complaints because people like me we
don't have money would have technology
we don't have a strong relationship the
only thing we competed with the others
is that how we see the future if I
believe the future like this way and
those people believe that way of course
we are different and when we believe
that is the future we start to do it we
study spend time we start to gather
people we said do little by little
if you want more Jack my motivation
check out the video right there next to
me I think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
I did I have a rich father not from you
know well educated I said I tried three
times for University all filled